a year or so ago I came across my
uncle's thesis when he was an economist
at Stanford and he coined the term
information economy and wrote his
dissertation on how the economy was
shifting from an industrial economy to
an information economy and it was
fascinating to go through his 9 vol
dissertation and start to understand how
the economy has evolved over time I sort
of always assumed the economy was more
or less the way it is but what I came to
realize was that we started off as
hunters and gatherers and that's how we
were able to survive but then we learned
how to use the land and animals and to
settle down and created an agrarian
economy and this it lasted thousands of
years but then we turn into an
industrial economy we start learning how
to make machines and we start being able
create assembly lines and it radically
changed our whole economy or society etc
and that what happened in the 1960s is
we actually had a shift where we went
from this industrial economy where the
economy was about how we made things I
was about manufacturing into this
information economy which was about
everything from TV and radio to
technology to eventually the internet
and it become the dominant part of the
economy and what was interesting in
looking at his research was not only the
economy had shifted but each of these
economies had gotten shorter and shorter
the agrarian economy was thousands of
years the Industrial is just a few
hundred and it seems likely that the
information economy wouldn't last that
long I may be much shorter than the
industrial economy and as I looked at
what are the things that gave us
indication the economy was shifting to
this information economy I started to
realize there were similar things that
were happening today there may be signs
that the economy is changing again that
we may be entering the fourth economy in
our history a fourth economy based on
advances and where we are as a society
what our needs are as a society and I
started looking around trying to figure
out what do all these different pieces
add up to and you started seeing books
an article showing up everywhere people
talking about sharing people talking
about maker economy now people are
making their own products to people
shopping and doing more around
experience all these different trends
that were happening throughout society
and I started drawing all these
different trends on a whiteboard showing
where they existed and how they
connected to each other and when I took
a step back something emerged
which is they were all fundamentally
about purpose and people's quest for
purpose they're about enhancing
relationships they are about doing
something greater than yourself
and they're about personal growth and
experience and when you looked at them
in totality they started to really
indicate that we were on the way to our
fourth economy that we are going to be
in likely the next ten years as
Millennials become the majority of our
workforce an economy where purpose is
the primary driver of economic output
and we're already seeing that and the
top innovations coming out of finance
education healthcare retail all the top
innovation is all around this need for
purpose and as you look at the workplace
all the changes were trying to make in
the workplace the things Google is doing
the things top companies are doing
they're all because especially the
millennial generation is demanding
purpose in their work at a level never
seen before and that's why I believe
we're in the early days of our fourth
economy of purpose economy so look
people ask like what is the purpose
economy and I think it's something that
I'm honestly still continuing to define
and to understand in every city I visit
I find new examples but there's some
common threads that bring it together I
think one is community I think with
technology and with the Industrial
Revolution and cars we've gotten to a
point where a lot of traditional
communities have gotten pulled apart and
what we see a lot of innovation that's
going into this new economy is about
getting back to neighborhoods getting
back to local business getting back to
being able to relate to your neighbors
and having schools truly embedded in
your neighborhood it's a much more
localized economy so that's one piece
the second really is a move away from
consumption to creation and experience
so whereas previous generations are very
focused on you know conspicuous
consumption consumption as a form of
entertainment and of itself we're seeing
more and more especially the millenials
a desire to be able to have experiences
and to have like more conspicuous
consumption of experience and we're
seeing more and more of a desire to
create and you see things like Etsy or
UC and like a lot of neighborhoods new
venues where you can go in and not just
buy things but make things you got to
build things yourself you see more
people do this in their homes you see
magazines and websites about
do-it-yourself the other major piece of
it is disintermediation we've gotten to
a point where there are these huge
organizations that make us so far
removed from each
I'm in marketplaces and you see this
with finance where finance used to be
about borrowing money from our neighbors
it became as a complicated algorithm as
part of an anonymous business and we're
now starting to see peer-to-peer lending
appear again so we're moving that
intermediary you see in health care how
we've had so many intermediaries get in
the middle between the doctor and the
patient and if you talk to the top
health care providers now they're now
moving towards goals of making sure that
medicine looks more like it did a
hundred years ago where house visits
where doctor actually came to you is the
norm not that you go see the doctor it's
removing these intermediaries these
institutions and bring us closer
together so there's some of the trends
that we see in this new economy